that what that brings me now we're going
to get a little political on you
but it's still we're still in the
context of sock puppetry and social
justice so
check this out it's actually really
interesting this is a story from the
washington free beacon
woke talking points cost gillibrand
primary support
oh snap i said this progressive rhetoric
loses politicians support new study
argues
it feels good to be vindicated yes it
does i've been saying for a long time
this is fringe political bs social
justice nonsense will not work but for
some reason
they just went for it so in the context
of
how you know social media has been being
manipulated
and they're putting these fringe
opinions out there they're actually
lighting themselves on fire
yeah i have to wonder if the real goal
is to make people like you vote for
donald trump
yeah right yeah you know what you know
from me do you know what black
propaganda is
no i saw you mention in a tweet yeah
there's there's
uh white gray and black okay uh white
propaganda is overt it would be like me
holding up a sign saying adam sucks
okay gray papa propaganda would be a
sign that just says
you know adam kriegler is a bad musician
you don't know who it comes from and
it's a negative opinion
okay and then black propaganda would be
someone saying like
adam kriegler is the best i love him
because he's racist
so the goal of black propaganda is to
pretend to be the enemy
and then look stupid ah okay or look
really bad right right
it's it's it's so so that people will
associate your opponents
with whatever stupid idea you've put
forward to accuse them of so
it would be like you know wearing a
trump shirt and then going
like like we've seen it people will put
like a trump shirt on and go around say
a bunch of racist things i actually i
was thinking of this i i saw this dude
who was a it was some rally or something
and
it was for the democrats right and he
had this this
swastika on his shirt that said trump
and pence
and he was like waving a flag around
like yelling at people
and then someone took a picture of him
and then later on they
saw the same picture of the guy like at
a bernie rally wearing no no the same
rally the dude like put his jacket on
and then like put the the sign down and
then like had this democrat flag
right it was like what so you just
staged yourself to look like
yeah that's called black propaganda
terrible we are going to get a ton of it
across the board and it is going to be
like april fool's day on crack
but you know what we'll be here calling
them out
yeah i guess we're stuck in the muck in
the mirror you know i know you're
better at it for me i mean i don't i'm
not that deep into politics but
the nightmarish reality of it is that
you know everything could be fake
it's somebody somebody made a joke a
while ago like what if all of these like
sjw leftists are actually right wingers
trying to make the leftist look bad
and then all the fringe like far right
people are actually leftist trying to
make the right look bad
and meanwhile regular people are like
what are you guys doing
yeah so this is funny the funny thing
about the gila brand stuff and i'll talk
about this then we'll talk about
more black propaganda is that this was
obvious to everybody
she ran her primary campaign for the
democrats going woke as possible
okay there was like one like some weird
candid
video where she's in a bar and she's
just like sitting there bobbing she goes
gay rights it's like so crazy
that was a commercial no it was like
someone just post a video of her doing
it it's like i don't
know so she just literally was doing
that yes she was at a bar just like
bobbing her is she by herself too
yeah it looked like it someone's got a
camera on her yep gay rights yep
i mean i'm all for gay rights but that
is hilarious it's so
i don't i don't know anybody who sat in
a bar by themselves
there were people around here dancing
and stuff but she's like in a bar
i don't know what she was doing so she
really really tried
it sounded like a photo op she's like oh
someone get this get this video i'm
about to i'm about to rock this sentence
out check the sentence out boom
you know what you know what my the
problem i have with it is
yeah what it's that one thing i really
can't stand is
inefficiency okay like when i see
something someone doing something wrong
like i want to be like yo stop like let
me let me just do it stop what you're
doing
like you're doing it wrong you've got it
upside down you got to flip it around
like
let me just do it give me the thing yep
so i'll do it myself yeah right like
i can't stand watching people like you
know trying to stick a square peg in a
round hole
i'm the same way i'm like hey you're
doing that wrong and everyone's like
i don't care i'm do it the way i want to
do it like let me do it
no then i'm just gonna have to fix it
when you're done anyway
because you're not doing it right yeah
and you guys that's why when it comes to
issues of like carpentry stuff i'm like
i'm not even gonna do anything i'm just
gonna
i'm just gonna call adam hey adam
because i don't do this well because you
know i'll tell you what happens right
i'll be like i'm going to hang this and
then animal come down be like oh bro
you missed the study like no i gotta fix
it and i'm like all right dude i'm just
not even gonna bother like you know
better than i do so i'll just
hand it off to you oh man but with with
gillibrand it was like watching someone
set themselves on fire
and i'm just like i've see i saw it at
fusion when i worked there
they they they this company they went
nuts right they had hundreds of millions
of dollars
they're like we're gonna do a media
company and we want to be you know like
non-partisan and like vice
and they had posters on the walls that
said we will not be partisan and stuff
seriously i kid you not and then all of
a sudden i mean i know what happened
that's why i'm laughing yeah someone
convinced them like
have you considered getting woke how
about partisanship maybe you should take
those posters down
there are some really really
embarrassing things this company did
really really really embarrassing things
so like apparently
i got to be very careful in details but
there was like a high level meeting
where this high level person is supposed
to be talking to a bunch of other
like marketing like advertising people
to like sell content okay
and when they were asked what was like
their mission
this person's like gender what
i'm not so i got i'm trying to be
careful here it's like like gay rights
all right i'm just gonna say it
i i might get in trouble but basically
they were producing this like sales
pitch
and the high-ranking person was asked
like what's the next
big you know story the big narrative and
he said gender
and that was supposed to be sent out to
advertising companies like you know coke
and pepsi or whatever
that's what i was told i could be wrong
but i was told this by like one of the
higher-ups who were like
face-palming like what are they doing
yeah what do you think's gonna happen
if you went to a meeting with like coke
and coke was like
we want to sell more soda what can you
do for us
gender i i'm sorry i'm not sure what
that means
not tracking infinity just go with it i
don't know
they thought they were young and edgy or
something you don't think it was
for a lot of these companies i was
actually told this by some
of the one of these consultant marketing
guys who said if you want a company that
starts today and is successful in five
years
you got to look at what young people are
talking about and then track that and
then
basically in five years you'll be that
source and i said the people talking
about that are like a microscopic
fraction of this country
and you're looking at the squeaky wheel
yeah regular people watch dave chappelle
and joe rogan
that's true and they're not they're
they're opposed to this stuff they let
themselves on fire flush down the toilet
coca-cola good for any gender oh yeah
there's uh
it doesn't have that that's there's like
there's like a meme about how all these
companies
know what was that monopoly thing you
see that commercial from another
i couldn't believe it was actually a
monopoly commercial that was awesome
that was awesome i still don't believe
it well let's give some context to the
people oh my god
so there there was a commercial and it
was like female engineers need to be
encouraged and it was like a little girl
and she's like i designed this you know
robot or whatever
like three or four different girls that
are like young and like want to be
scientists
yep and it's like it's three minutes of
talking about equal rights and
encouraging women yep
and then all of a sudden there's a scene
where it's like that's why we did this
and it shows a woman and a present this
little girl and she opens up
where did this come from i don't know
let's all sit in the couch and yeah and
watch you open it together and they're
all like sitting around as a family as
the girl sits
and it became a game the game was to
post the video and say
guess what they're promoting yep yep and
then you're watching it going like what
could it be and then when they when she
opens the package and it's miss monopoly
monopoly what it's it's the most
backwards insane thing i never i would
never have guessed it here's how the
game works never
the game works by like men get less
money than women
oh when they pass go okay so it's like
they want
so wait the original monopoly actually
has equal rights everyone's equal
and this this game was handicapping
women
to prove equality we're going to
handicap them wow
we're going to we're going to give them
a handicap i should say not handicap the
men will be handicapped
we'll give the benefit to the women it
sends the opposite message
it does that's true we live in women
need
need more help is that what you say you
know what it is that's exactly what it's
saying
it's that people uh people are stupid
oh is that it thank you for solving that
wow yeah yeah you got a point he's gotta
imagine
imagine what uh imagine what communism
would be like
all of these people you know it's like
like the monopoly version or whatever no
what i mean is
no the socialist monopoly is dumb i
tried playing it but uh no but how would
the communist version go i'm not talking
about monopoly i'm talking about real
life
i'm talking about how we can watch them
fail and laugh and
no one's hurt by it they launched a
really stupid commercial everyone made
fun of them
i'm sure they sold some of them but they
mocked and they were berated
it under a command economy you have
these ideal logs in government being
like nope we're going to keep making it
anyway
reminds me of uh the feature album
episode i love citing feature elements
yes you do when they go to the amazon
planet
snooze now yeah and they and they see
them playing basketball
yeah and the the wins like they know can
dunk but good fundamentals
like the the point is
supporting something that they don't
like because it's just
it feels it's like emotionally you know
yeah so you have
in in capitalism things can fail and we
can laugh about it
true and communism now you get one
ideologue who's gonna be like make miss
monopoly
sir nobody wants it don't care keep
making it and then
you just waste resources and light
things on fire yeah
speaking of you know and i'm only going
to say this very briefly
but we were talking earlier about like
universal healthcare oh really and how
the post office was awful
and then i said imagine imagine getting
your healthcare through the post office
system
right imagine getting your healthcare
through the dmv
i want everyone to think about universal
healthcare i think i'm good and then i
want to imagine going to the dmv but
instead of trying to get your license
done
or you know copied whatever you're
trying to get life altering life
life-saving surgery
oh my gosh bro i went to the dmv no
thanks i went to the dmv
to get my car license license plate and
they gave me a
trailer plate and i didn't i didn't know
what it meant
trailer plate yeah for for like a hitch
trailer you put on the back of the car
yeah yeah yeah
i didn't know so in florida you only
need i think i'm pretty sure in florida
you only need a plate in the back
so they gave me one plate it said
trailer and i was like
is this right and she's like you're all
good and i'm like okay oh wow i didn't
know that because it's the first time i
got in a license plate in jersey
yeah so i assumed you needed one plate
in the back and it's a trailer because
it was the back of the car or something
yeah
and so then i came back and i put it on
and went about my business and then i
saw i
walked inside and i'm like that can't be
right yeah so i went online and looked
it up and i was like oh man
you dumb i had to go back that sucks
and it's like dealing with the dmv
waiting in line uh do you talk about a
nightmare
twice well let's let's go back to the
black propaganda thing
so when when you see uh kirsten
gillibrand
yelling gay rights or whatever yeah and
you see all these people and all these
media companies
i wonder if the goal was to destroy them
you know what every time we we have
different conversations about different
points
you know of the whole bubble of politics
and the more you say it the more
it does make sense that they're just
trying to sabotage themselves
not themselves but there's people trying
to destroy them uh okay
like this you know fusion won't start a
company they
abc and univision have this plan they
put in hundreds of millions of dollars
and then they start looking for
consultants and someone comes in and
thinks how can i destroy this company
you know and you know what what makes me
curious is
there was very very heavy hillary
clinton influence
in in in what fusion was doing okay uh
so i gotta i'll be very very careful
about
how far i go with that but big powerful
donors there was just it was in the
family you know what i mean yeah yeah
so i had to wonder if one of them one of
the reasons they decided to go full on
feminist was because they wanted to
create a narrative so that when hillary
clinton ran
they'd be like you know we're for her
but i don't i don't
and i a lot of people would argue it's a
big conspiracy theory it's like it's not
a conspiracy theory for
some for this big hillary clinton donor
to pay for media
like it's marketing that's just regular
old marketing yeah they put money in and
say write stories that make her look
good they do that all the time
so i had to wonder if that was the goal
a lot of people told me it wasn't they
were just trying to make money
sure and i'm like but why would you make
content that's only for women then why
wouldn't you make content
you know but they were making money
doing what they were doing why would
they change
they weren't making money oh i thought
you said they were they were doing fine
like
when they first started they were trying
to figure things out they were just
funded that's what you said
and then they started they had
consultants come in and tell them to do
something
yeah and they flushed themselves down
the toilet and burned all the money
yeah but when it comes to the internet
and uh like people like gila brand and
stuff i have to wonder if
one of the reasons the left can't
succeed is because
black propaganda like if all this
canceled culture stuff is just people
trying to make sure they can never
succeed
i think about it in terms of real
leftist anti-establishment activists
okay
you can see people like matt taibi for
instance he wrote this article he's a
journalist he's a lefty
he wrote an article saying the democrats
have abandoned civil liberties
he's a real he's a real like moderate
lefty guy certainly
seems that way nowadays right he talked
about how you know he used to
align with the democrats and now he sees
them as like they've gone nuts yep
and so many many other people there's
activists know that the lengths that the
feds have gone to to disrupt
you know activist organizations what's
the easiest way to totally discredit
left-wing anti-establishment
organizations
get in there get in there and screech
and re and throw bricks and cheer
on all the really really awful stuff and
then
create this narrative and just and
damage them now i think they do it to
themselves if they're
that easily susceptible to this kind of
you know manipulation
but you get people to go online and say
something like i'm voting for bernie
sanders by the way
you know i hate all you know and name a
group yeah
or push that narrative or do what
kirsten gillibrand
she fell for it i guess i don't know i
don't know let's tell you man she's
she that was so obvious she was going to
fail yep
well anyway we're going to be in the
thick of things i hope you are all
excited for the roller coaster ride that
will be
2020s i know i am i'm looking forward to
it dude they're going to call you all
the names in the book
i can't wait it's going to be great adam
this this vegan
skateboarder is the epitome of far right
man i've been called all sorts of things
throughout my life i just don't care
i don't care you either like me or you
don't like me and that's that's how it
goes
but they do it to try and scare you to
destroy your life
if you're susceptible to that yes right
without naming any specific individual
there are people who
would make content that was like
anti-sjw you know moderate not super
political but like anti you know in the
culture war
okay ntsw and then once they got their
careers threatened
immediately started saying oh but i'm
actually left wing oh and then
totally just slowly sneaking in and then
there are people on the uh who did
it but then there are people in the
middle do the same thing okay and then
slowly become more and more right wing
and start entertaining more
more conservative right-wing positions
and it's because they're getting what's
called a love bomb from the right
okay and so that's like the the ongoing
phenomenon right now the culture war
the love bomb come have some beers yup
yup and then
everyone's response that is like i know
which side i would go to
the side where it's like have a beard
with me that makes sense not the one
that's screeching and trying to destroy
me
yeah but some some people fall for it
there are some high-profile uh
progressives who made pretty good
progressive but fair content
until they got attacked and got
cancelled and then all of a sudden
all of a sudden they started towing the
line yeah and and saying all the stupid
saw stuff and i'm like
it was too late no they're losers yeah
they're they're and they're people i
used to follow and promote i don't
promote them anymore
because i'm like you used to call it out
like if you believe in universal
healthcare and you don't have an
argument about what i just said about
the dmv
and there's real arguments against that
just because the dmv is bad doesn't mean
you can't make a system for universal
healthcare that works properly
yeah yeah i think there's a lot of
problems to it i lean towards more of a
public option because you need
competition
and and we i think we talked about this
like there could be emergency care is
universal
right right right specialty stuff like
breaking your leg right
you can go get it taken care of right
right but if you chemotherapy
crap for your entire life and got you
know and drank alcohol
and then got some sort of weird cancer
that was from that it's like
you have to pay for that yeah you did
that to yourself so
if you want to make a have a real
conversation and a fair argument stuff
like i'm totally down but it seems like
that doesn't really exist for the most
part because the screeching wreaths
you know the social justice warriors
prevent these kind of conversations and
make sure
everyone's just maybe it's just humans
man maybe it's just how we are
not as a whole i think you can't
stop some people from being that way
though that's just gonna be the way it
is
this is what i was saying about the
media they cheat
and cheaters win yep you know you know
what's funny they they
what what do they say cheaters never win
is that like i was told that when i was
younger winners never cheat cheaters
never win
that's not true at all that is a lie
cheaters win
all the time and the smart ones never
get caught and what about that uh what
is that line uh history's written by the
winners
yep it's true it is i know exactly
unfortunately
and he was right although bad timing but
no
the full context of his statement was he
laughed and said
he was he was asked how will history
look back on you know what happened and
he laughs well history is written by the
winner so i guess we can see but i think
it'll look favorable favorably honest
because we upheld the rule of law
right and then chuck todd said he didn't
even argue that he upheld the rule of
law
that was the problem he he literally
lied about what bilbar actually
the fake news they get away with it they
make money and the controversy is still
good for them you know why
there are people who don't care they're
lying they like that they're lying yeah
that's true
because what you just said fits what i
believe
so it vindicates what i believe now i
can yell louder
yeah and even then because i have proof
not even that
it's like they believe that they're
justified in lying
to convert people because i would say
both because the ends justify the means
it's a religion
both so when when chuck todd lies they
know he's lying and they go good
because it'll convert more people no i
don't think everyone knows that they're
lying i think some people just
want to believe it they're like oh he's
saying what i believe so but the dude
matthew iglesias of vox.com once wrote
that progressive messaging had
successfully convinced
people they had not received a tax break
when they really did
and that was a success a messaging
success that is amazing he celebrated
the fact that they had successfully lied
to people
and tricked them into hating trump for
something he actually helped them on mom
yeah welcome and how do you think it's
going to get moving into november
i mean people are becoming aware of
they're seeing all this stuff that
mainstream media is losing it's i feel
like
it's falling through their fingers and
they're like what do we do now what do
we do now
oh cnn's going full reality tv are they
good yeah so we talked about the greta
thing right yeah yeah
anderson cooper went on some tired where
he's like donny trump jr wants to
you know drag us shouldn't he be running
his companies and i'm like why is
anderson cooper getting into a like
you know internet style flame war with
donald trump jr over
like a tweet why trump jr tweeted about
greta so anderson cooper dedicated a
segment to just like
seriously it was like a segment on scene
it was it was it was a short bit where
he ragged on like
the online outrage machine over the
greta tunberg thing oh
and i'm like they love it they're so
happy yeah they are jeff zucker the
president of cnn was a reality reality
tv guy
it's probably why they brought him on
they were like look man news doesn't
work anymore
you know you know it reminds me of
remember when people were complaining
about mtv no longer doing music
yeah yeah mtv i was just thinking about
ftd mtv i'm like
yeah mtv used to be awesome in the 90s
it was all music videos yeah and then
you had like mtv news slowly
they started adding these reality tv
programs and then eventually that's all
it is no more music videos
yeah and i remember that period where
they were doing like trl like total
request live yeah
they wouldn't even show the whole music
video it would be like a minute and a
half of it yeah and i'd be like this is
crazy like
they they're thinking like we gotta kind
of do it but we're not gonna do it yeah
right
but then that was like the early odds
where it started changing yeah
and there was there was a post someone
made like it was like a viral post i
can't remember
where where it was but someone said you
don't even watch mtv anymore
and you're complaining that they found a
new audience that's more receptive to a
different kind of content
just face it you're you're you've grown
out of what they offered
there's other ways to get music there's
easier ways to get music so they've
changed
that's kind of true you had the internet
it's true so why complain about the fact
that they've changed
the problem with with cnn is they're
supposed to be quote the most trusted
name and news
right i can't hear that and not laugh
yeah i know it's really
you you see the commercial were like
this is an apple
some people will tell you it's a banana
or something like that
it's the cringiest stupidest who tells
anyone that an apple is a banana sienna
i've never seen them yeah they're the
only ones yeah that would be that
that's what they've become and so look i
don't care geez
so so here here's where i where i draw
the line when i was talking about like
you know we're complaining about them
complaining about rick and morty it's
like the difference is
we're calling them out for lying yeah
and i think that's fair
and when we do opinion segments we're
just two dudes hanging out in a home
studio talking about how we feel
with people who share similar feelings
and lydia and me
i got you lydia all right right that's
right three people here
dude and lydia yeah but uh
cnn is supposed to be telling us the
facts yeah
they're not they're not not you know
what it is they can't compete with us
nope so they because we got true fans
where's my camera yeah there we go
that's right you guys are great i
appreciate you guys
and see you now i'm talking about you
fans and cnn has to pay the airport
right they do
they have to move to eric it's
embarrassing cnn pays
airports to put them on the next time
you're stuck in an airport think about
that
so anyway anyway we gotta i want to talk
about space
so let me just wrap this up and say
there's going to be a ton of people
banned
there's going to be social media
suppression you're going to see brigade
campaigns so recently on reddit and i
want to be very careful so i'm going to
avoid calling out specific people but
there have been brigade campaigns
what they'll do is they try to pretend
like they're fans of yours that are
disheartened okay
like i used to be such a biggest fan of
adam you really changed adam
i think you gotta get get back to
reality and start talking about you know
about why the republicans are bad i
think you've lost sight of reality
things like that okay it's it's very
obvious
but that's the attempt to manipulate you
so it's it's part of the black
propaganda thing
you might go on twitter one day and see
like 50 messages where they're like bro
dude dude i love you man that show's
awesome but hey when you mention this
thing that's not cool
and then you see all these messages and
think everyone's mad at you and you go
oh i better not say that again
it's a trick yeah i don't even check my
notifications i'm like i don't care dude
don't don't care absolutely don't don't
care anything people have tagged me with
some uh
some funny stuff that they click they
straight up tell me they hate me
yeah and that's okay that's cool thanks
for taking the time to uh
at least hit me up that's great you know
what i always say
when i was little i was told the
opposite of love isn't hate it's
indifference
okay because it is like indifference is
like you care you like you don't even
think about the person
right love and hate are both very
powerful emotions you're thinking about
me
you can love someone you can hate me but
you're still thinking about it you can
hate someone you love
like you can actually love someone but
just hate them that's a good point it's
true so they're not opposites yeah so if
somebody says they hate you
then you've successfully won you you've
won them over and over
they're now in their hearts that's right
you're their head forever rent free
rent free in their heads i always you
know i always say things like
i i'm when people tweet at me and say
nasty things and go on facebook
i'm like my honest feeling about this
is a weird sense of like accomplishment
yeah okay you know like growing up being
a high school dropout and not getting to
the point where they're all these people
that feel like i'm important enough to
where they have to complain about me to
their friends
it's kind of a crazy feeling like i it's
kind of like free advertising also
because then their friends are like who
is this guy this guy i gotta check out
this tin pool guy
yeah oh actually he's pretty good but
it's also like he's not bad when i'm in
new york
and there's uh i would say for the most
part the people who recognize me are
like yo dude you're awesome
yeah then the guy was like are you tim
pool i'm like i live right here dude
like a block away from my house he
freaked out that was cool
i was like cute no the craziest the
craziest thing was when i was in iceland
and i was in this middle of nowhere and
i went to a burger joint and two guys
walked in they stopped they're like
are you tim poole and i was like i'm
sorry i'm sorry no nothing beats billy
corgan
he's going tim poole oh yeah i met billy
carter that
that just that's like yeah did i tell
you the icing on the cake you did tell
the story yeah yeah
that's the icing of the cake the first
time i met billy corgan i was all
excited because i you know
listened to the pumpkins and uh and he
was standing there and then as i was
being introduced he stops and goes hey
you're tim poor and i watch your videos
and i was like whoa
yeah i was like that's so cool yeah red
i was i was at a premiere for one of his
new albums that dude's cool apparently
he's like
someone mentioned he saw someone turn
into a lizard i guess yeah i don't know
about all that but
uh billy corkin smashing pumpkins great
band so uh no but anyway i i
agreed what i i forgot what i was trying
to bring up when i mentioned
being recognized because i wasn't trying
to make it talking about living rent
free in their heads
yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say when
people when people in new york yell f
you tim pool
i'm like man that guy really cares yeah
thank you dude
really cares yeah i appreciate it like
it's funny the guy who said that he
hates me he like
did this whole rant and then i click on
his profiles like who's this guy let's
see this
and it says stop bullying
i freaking love it that was in his
profile i was like
sounds like an sjw good for you sir good
for you sir
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you